the international monetary fund is
warning that the new omicron coronavirus
variant is likely to delay the global
economic recovery from the pandemic the
fund is expecting to downgrade its
forecasts for world growth this year and
next and that's even though the world
health organization says it has no
evidence yet of any deaths connected to
omicron the new variant is spreading
rapidly in many countries south africa
in particular is seeing an alarming wave
of infections more young children are
being hospitalized and authorities are
concerned that people who've already had
covid19 are being re-infected
healthcare workers in south africa have
had their hands full since scientists
there first detected the omicron variant
last week and it's been found across
south africa
we are also now experiencing such a
rapid surge in in case numbers that it
is actually uh quite frightening
i am moderately confident that the
country will be able to cope
on the other hand the the the rapidly
increasing numbers are you know are a
nasty surprise and i wonder what the
future holds for us
just a quarter of the population have
been fully vaccinated
but it's not clear yet how far the
current vaccines protect against an
infection with omicron
we are seeing a lot of breakthrough
infections in vaccines which is of
course a worry we are also seeing
re-infections in people who had
previously been infected during one of
the previous waves
but the majority of infections so far
are mild that's it we have to say that
it's still early days and and as we know
uh you know to to become clinically
severe um there will have to be 10 to 14
days or more
after becoming infected so it's probably
too early to tell
south africa's public health authorities
warn that more children and young adults
are being hospitalized with the
coronavirus
many countries have placed new
restrictions on travellers from south
africa
and even shut borders
and the scientists who alerted the world
to the omicron variant are facing a
backlash at home
but critics
within the country that is now very hard
hit by all these travel bans um they are
blaming us the scientists for actually
doing sequencing and and
sharing our results which i think is not
not is quite misguided
face masks are mandatory and there are
limits on the number of people who can
attend indoor and outdoor gatherings
but omicron continues its invisible race
across south africa
and for more we can speak to journalists
and molecular biologist kai kupashmit
who joins us from here in berlin it's
good to have you on the program again
now scientists say the omicron variant
is spreading more than twice as quickly
as the delta variant we just heard there
more kids are being
hospitalized how worried do we really
need to be
well i think so scientists are still
trying to get a clearer picture of what
exactly omnicom has in store it you know
imagine a big puzzle and we're only just
getting the first puzzle pieces but
certainly those first puzzle pieces you
know all add to the concern we now have
some preliminary data that shows that
this virus can in fact reinfect people
certainly people who've had who've gone
through an infection before and
recovered and and it does seem to be
spreading very fast though that's always
very hard to tell in the early days
whether there are you know certain super
spreading events for instance that make
it appear to be spreading faster than it
actually will in the long run but
certainly um i think if we've learned
anything from the last two years is that
in a situation like this you know we
should rather act fast and be worried
right now and then you know breathe a
sigh of relief if we actually if it
doesn't turn out to be as bad
right now the world health organization
is saying that it has no evidence of any
deaths linked to omicron
yet countries are racing to impose
stricter pandemic measures travel bans
are in place
would you say all of these restrictions
are an overreaction
so i i don't think it's an overreaction
i i do think that travel bans you know
you have to be very careful about what
you do with travel bans all they do is
buy you a little bit of time and they
only make sense for a very short time
because once the virus spreads you know
wide in your own communities anyway it
doesn't really make sense to impose them
and they have a you know fairly big cost
uh attached to them so
but but the fact that we haven't seen
any deaths so far in the in in south
africa from omicron doesn't really tell
us that much yet because it's still
really early days we know that it takes
you know two weeks for people once they
go to the hospital and then for for
deaths actually to to be reported
so i think at the moment i wouldn't read
too much into it i mean we're all kind
of hoping that maybe you know it does
turn out to be a milder variant that
spreads fast but is milder but we really
can't say that at the moment and we
certainly shouldn't pin our hopes on
that and
not act and prepare
okay so obviously there's a lot more to
learn about this variant but of course
omicron is the latest in a string of
coronavirus mutations since the start of
the pandemic do we need to prepare
ourselves for a potentially never-ending
series of new mutations or you know is
there anything that governments around
the world could be doing better to try
and bring this to an end
well what's very clear is that as long
as this virus
can spread in this you know huge amount
of people that it is spreading in at the
moment
mutations will keep arising and some of
those mutations will give this virus
advantages whether in transmissibility
or in reinfecting people it might get
around vaccine immunity and that's just
something that we have to live with
unless we really try to do the hard work
of suppressing the numbers i mean we do
have some experience with a virus that
keeps changing that's the flu
and of course
it might very well be that this turns
into a virus that stays with us that's
certainly what it looks like that that
source cov2 will be with us for the long
run but even then we are going to have
to do the hard work of making sure that
we're prepared for every season when it
comes and just hope that it does indeed
over time become a little bit milder but
that's by no means a given
all right kai cup for schmidt as ever
thank you so much
thank you
okay let's take a look now at some more
developments in the pandemic
germany's biontech says it should be
able to adapt its covert 19 vaccine
swiftly to deal with the omicron variant
the czech republic is preparing to
mandate vaccinations for people over 60
as well as for medical workers and
police and a man in italy wore a fake
silicon arm to try and trick a nurse
into giving him a jab so that he could
get a covert 19 health certificate